what's up guys so we all know the SSDs
and hard drives are like day and night
SSDs are just so much faster and make
your PC experience significantly better
however asses these are still quite a
bit more expensive than hard drives and
just don't provide as much storage as a
hard drive would for the same price
as a result all of us we don't have
crazy extreme bills I only have nvme
drives we still have to buy a hard drive
even if we are getting SSD based
necessity simply does not provide enough
storage one of these popular hard drives
is the Seagate Barracuda 2 terabyte hard
drive there are many other hard drives
out there which are all priced the same
so it's very difficult to differentiate
between them so today I'm going to be
taking a look at the Seagate Barracuda
hard drive 2 terabyte and hope you guys
are turn if this is a drive you guys
should get so if starting off this drive
costs $60 you can install it very easily
into any build there are just two cables
that you need to plug in and you're
ready to go
it's really that easy to install that's
it you're done then you guys can install
any games or any programs you want onto
it or just use as a drive for documents
and pictures and other stuff like that
it's as simple as that
so that's how you get your hard drive up
and running but how does it perform well
on paper the Barracuda is a 7200 rpm
hard drive it has a 64 megabyte buffer
size and a sequential read of 210
megabytes per second and a sequential
write of 156 megabytes per second these
are the advertised numbers
but now let's take a look at the real
numbers according to a SSD benchmark the
sequential read is a hundred and seventy
nine point zero nine megabytes per
second the sequential write it was 150
eight point one megabytes per second the
4k read was 0.25 nine megabytes per
second and the 4k write was zero point
nine five megabytes person
the reading access time was 18 point 501
milliseconds and the writing access time
was twenty point five to four
milliseconds these numbers aren't
exactly the advertised numbers but you
do have to keep in mind that this test
was for the SSD and the system was using
the hard drive in the background for
other functions during this test next
let's take a look at some daily use
applications and see how this affects
daily use the average boot temps for
this drive is from the high 30s to low
40s After Effects takes upward of one
minutes load and Premiere Pro and
Photoshop pick at least 30 seconds as it
is evident this drive really isn't super
fast but it wasn't built to deliver full
performance it was built for storage of
documents and hold other personal items
that don't require accurate performance
from the drive overall performance from
this program is not the best but it
really delivers mass storage and enough
speed for its lower asking price of 60
dollars as a result the drive definitely
delivers a big value as asking price
because it has mass storage and really
blows away any SSD or nvme drive on the
market in value for how many gigabytes
are getting form your money this drive
is actually on the cheaper side of hard
drives that are made by other big
companies like Western Digital blue 2
terabyte hard drive which costs 65
dollars but at the same time is also
slower at only 5400 rpm at the end of
this day at the end of the day this hard
drive is one of the best value hard
rests on the market right now and it's
really worth every cent this drive isn't
meant for performance or speedy boot
times it's meant for mass storage for
documents and photos if you guys are
really after speed you guys should get
SSD which I recommend you guys all get
because the nessus D is a big upgrade
you guys can make to a PC in terms of
speed as a result SSD is really worth it
even if it puts you guys above your
budget even if it's only a 120 gigabyte
SSD as well anyways getting back to this
hard drive this hard drive is absolutely
the value King on the market right now
and it's really a good purchase for you
guys for your mass storage needs overall
I would recommend these hard drive for
you guys if you guys are planning to use
this drive to just store Word documents
and things of that nature on top of an
SSD if you guys don't already have an
SSD then you guys just just get a one
terabyte hard drive and use that money
save some more money and get a cheap SSD
on top of the one terabyte hard drive
because an SSD really is worth it as a
result is it perfect buy from a storage
on top of an SSD however I don't
recommend that you guys get this as a
place to install windows on and your
games you guys should really get an SSD
for that ultimately that's not on this
hard drive is in my opinion the best
hard drive that you guys get on the
market and delivers the best market
value right now well guys that's all I
have for you guys on this video if you
guys like this video and tiwa cell phone
make sure to drop a like on this video
if you guys loved it and would like to
see more videos just like this make sure
to subscribe and hit download off'
occation that's all I have for you guys
right now
and until next video bye